[Music]
all right let's go to john
in stafford arizona what's up brother
john how are we doing
doing good how are you dr deloney we're
rocking on man to break a dawn
what's up dude how can i help so
i read your book redefining anxiety and
i really liked it there's a lot of
really good stuff in there
thanks man the question i have though
is about you talk about your body's
warning signals
throughout the book and i
personally have a hard time turning off
those signals
oh very cool man i do
pretty good at talking myself through
situations and
understanding when anxiety hits but
even when i like sometimes when i
resolve a problem
and i forget about the problem i still
feel that anxiety
in me and i still feel like something's
wrong like my body's in danger
yeah dude good for you man so number one
thanks for reading the book and number
two
man you are in it now so you're thinking
through
so your body takes off on you or you
find yourself in a situation
um to beat the metaphor to death you're
identifying these alarms
are you able to look at your overall
ecosystem and say
oh here's what those alarms are trying
to tell me
uh most of the time yeah okay so give me
a couple of examples of things you found
um the one that comes to mind the most
when i think about it is if i get
something wrong at work or something
my boss will come and tell me about it
and he's like a saint about
it he always is talking to me well
moving forward we're gonna do this
better and
he's sure to tell me like i'm okay and
everything
but it's still like even when that
resolves and i
know that everything's okay i still it
just
lingers there with me throughout the day
all right so
that is a great example dude um just
for my own curiosity has
anyone told you shown you in your past
that
that you suck
um i mean yeah
um did your mom dad brother sister
remind you on none none of them they
were good
no i i was bullied in elementary school
ah quite a bit okay so
here's and again we you and i could
probably talk for a couple of hours
on the trajectory in the history there
um
here's a cool thing to note about your
body okay so your boss comes in and says
hey you didn't do this right
and for a hundred reasons whether it's
stories you're born into whether it's
stories you've told yourself
well there are stories that people in
all the way back as elementary school
were telling you about your value you're
a loser you're an idiot you always screw
this up whatever those stories are
your body detects a threat it sees a
bear at the front of the cave where
you're living
and it has an old operating system man
it's got
fight it or run away from it
and that's about it it can
if he doesn't realizes i can't fight it
i can't run away from it i'll just
go to neutral i'll shut this thing off
right i'll shut the system down you may
have heard that called freeze right
but your boss can come look in the eye
and say man i love you i'm so glad you
work here
your boss can come tell you hey you
screwed this one up man with a smile on
his face but we got to get this one
better next time i need you to step up
and do this right
at that point your body has gone into
fight or flight because it's got a
history it remembers this story when
somebody come up and told you you are
not of value
right you don't have worth and then he
looks at you and says hey
you're on my team i love you i'm so glad
you're here and now we're on to the next
thing
your body still has to deal with the
cortisol and the adrenaline
and the heart rate right your body is
taking off on you
and what we don't have a good system in
modern
or modern world is what to do with that
does that make sense
right it's just there so there's a
couple of things i want to give you
to back out of this so we're going to
approach this two ways number one what
do you do when your body
just detects a threat even though
there's no threat in
in your vicinity right so we can deal
with that
the other thing i want to do is begin to
teach my body
what is a threat and what's not does
that make sense we're gonna just reteach
it because we're gonna it's gonna
it's gonna literally grow new synapses
and new brain connections
in in my head does that make sense
so what we want to do is turn off a lot
of the signaling
stuff so here's a couple of ideas i'm
going to rattle these off just for the
sake of time
and you can keep this
um this call keep it in your library man
and we will link to the stuff in the
show notes and um
but i want you to write this stuff down
eventually and keep it as a playbook for
yourself
okay so will you work with me for 30
days
on this will you give yourself 30 days
60 days to start
re-connecting some new teaching your
body new things
yeah okay awesome so number one
no monster drinks or red bulls or
anything like that
is that cool already done all right
great are you a coffee guy
no so you're like a no caffeine dude no
cokes anything like that
i have my dr pepper every once in a
while but that's about it
okay you get two of those for the next
30 days how about that okay
okay all right the second thing is is
tell me about your friends
community you have any folks that you
connect with on a regular basis
um there's my wife and her family
they don't count you go and connect yeah
um just my friends at work and i have a
couple of friends that
i talk to every once in a while all
right so new responsibility checklist
number so number one you're gonna cut
out the
stimulant stuff right we are working
towards this
so um i have folks who for years my
students would come and be like man i'm
so anxious all the time
i only had seven red bulls and four
monster energy drinks today
well it's like dude you're not you're
your heart is beating a thousand
so we're getting rid of that stuff we're
gonna really dial back
sugar consumption candy junk food just
stuff we're ripping out of packages and
just shoving in our face okay
we're gonna give our body a good system
to work with
the second thing is we are going to
double down on relationships so your job
is to get with a couple of guys and go
do a thing once a week
at minimum and that can be going to an
arcade that can be going a bar that can
be i don't care what y'all do
but i want you to go get with a couple
of guys and it's going to be awkward
it's going to be weird
and you don't have to have any agenda or
anything like that y'all just go hang
out
okay that could be asking people at work
that you trust
like hey let's just go hang out we're
gonna go to a movie we're gonna go
whatever concert whatever i don't care
what it is but y'all gotta go do
something go bowling
go do something okay um the third thing
do you ever
exercise work out or anything like that
um not a whole lot my work is pretty
labor intensive but not anything more
than that
okay so starting today you've got some
sort of
movement practice that's gonna also
if you can be outside okay so if you
work a really
labor-intensive job if you're slinging
boxes all day
then i want you to make sure in the
mornings you go for a walk
in the evenings after dinner as a
post-perennial glucose
i want you to go for a long walk and you
can i'd love for you to take your wife
with you on this one or your dog
and i want you all to go for a long walk
together and i want you to go slow
and i want you to breathe deep and what
we're doing here man is we are cycling
that
we're cycling that excess energy out of
our bodies okay
that pent up ah that's all there we're
letting it roll
okay the next thing i want you to do do
you keep any sort of gratitude journal
at all
um not written down now you do know
starting today before bed i want you to
get on your way home from work i want
you to stop at like walgreens or walmart
or something 99 cents pick up a spiral
notebook
um and i want you to write at the top of
it gratitude journal and i want you to
write five things before you go to bed
that start with the words i am grateful
for and i don't care
what you put in there i'm grateful for
my mine this morning i i i'm working on
a book so i was up late so
i got i looked at my sleep tracker and
had like four hours of sleep last night
my first thing was i'm grateful for my
air-conditioned house it's hot in
nashville and that
i grateful for my air conditioning i was
grateful for my kids and my wife i was
grateful for
my faith community and my friend right
so whatever it is
at night five things and since you're
working on your body what you do in the
morning too so the first thing you do
when you wake up
i'm grateful for at night i am grateful
for
five things okay you got it okay
now here's the next most important thing
i want you to have another spiral
and when your body takes off on you
i want you to use language that is third
person
and i want you to be curious have fun
with this and i know that sounds
nuts and listen i've been doubled over
insane with anxiety so i get what i'm
saying sounds bananas
but i want you to be
intentional about being curious and have
fun and i want you to ask this question
john what's your body doing
and i want you to write down your
answers what is it protecting you from
in that tone of voice okay and i don't
want you to say what is
my what am i trying to there's actually
different brain circuits when you say
the words i
my there is a i'm in it
there's a set of brain circuits when you
are distant from it
there's a different set of brain
circuits that work on that problem it's
why somebody can come up to you and say
hey man i'm really feeling anxious and
you
john can rattle off five or six things
they need to go do but when you're
feeling anxious it locks down on you
right or when somebody asks you hey
what's the way
my wife could you give all that kind of
answers but then when your wife does it
you're like i don't know i don't know i
don't know
because one of those circuits is when
you're in it and those others when
you're distant from it
it's a great book uh by eric crop i
think called chatter
um it's a quick book but it was
excellent about talking about
how to distance yourself so i want you
to write down hey john what's your body
trying to tell you what is it scared of
right now
it's probably going to come back to a
story you've told yourself for a long
time that you're a loser that you're
going to screw something up
that everyone doesn't like you that
you're a failure
that you're always an idiot and it's
probably going to come back to bullying
in high school it's going to come back
to some coach it's going to come back to
a mom or a dad
who should have told you they loved you
and they didn't whatever it looks like
but that's how you're going to begin to
unwind those stories what's my body
trying to tell me
hey john what's your body trying to tell
you right now oh that
i'm gonna get fired and then the final
thing is i want you
to demand evidence from those things
okay
i just want you to ask hey john is that
true then you can go
no it's not true john he told you i love
having you on this team right i love
having you on this team
so grateful for that you're here but hey
we can't throw boxes like that we gotta
do it like this next time
love being married to you man but man
will you please take the trash out
every alarm goes off ah she's gonna
leave oh she's just nagging oh [ __ ]
oh hey john what is your body trying to
tell you oh that i failed my wife
is that true no it's not i need to take
trash out or
i'm failing my wife yeah i need to take
the trash right whatever it is
but get some distance from it and write
it down
and one last thing grab while you're at
walgreens grab a package of note cards
and just write out your morning whenever
you're about to leave for work here's
what i got to do today
keep a small note card with you just put
in your pocket you can go spend a
thousand dollars one of those planners
with like 500 ribbons in it
enough with the ribbon planners people
you can go get one of those or you can
just get a note card it's what i use
i got two in my pocket right now because
i didn't finish everything from
yesterday
and so um get a no chord and that's
control
right so going back to connection safety
and control and then you're just gonna
start pulling apart those stories man
but you my brother are on the right
track those are a few
simple things you can do if you feel
your body spin out on you
once you're in a your boss is laughter
go outside and go for a walk for a
minute in the sunshine go for a walk
if you can if you want to be a nerd
about it take your shoes off and walk in
the grass
i was doing that the other day here at
the office and somebody took a picture
of me and several people took pictures
of me and they're like hey you look like
a weirdo
um but i'll go walk in the grass
barefoot right and there's that's a
whole other podcast but
um and breathe through it
and just be curious what are you trying
to protect me from right now
and there's something about not fighting
letting your body know we're not
fighting we're not running
what are you doing and often your body
will go oh
oh you're in control okay cool and it
will stop that system
and then you got to discharge the
cortisol the adrenaline all those
chemicals all that energy that's been
fired up in there
right we're running on old operating
systems and then of course sleep man you
know all that stuff sleep and
supplements and
partridge in a pear tree that's another
thing that's enough to keep you busy
after 30 days i want you to write me
back call me back and you can call that
dude and say that
all that stuff was stupid none of that
worked it will
but call me back